[Musique]
bonsoir c'est tout le monde
patricia gagnon laurent richier mathilde
seigner stéphane bern
[Musique]
alors en fait on vous a invité parce
qu'il va être beaucoup de questions que
vous à mon avis d'ici l'été
mais aussi pour une autre raison est
absolument pour une autre raison c'est
que vous avez dit que laurent gerra
était rigolo et intelligent alors la
maman comme vous avez la fiancée de
laurent gerra devant vous effectivement
vous êtes déjà de très copains alors
jack lang
vous avez une forme éblouissante ouais
c'est vrai il a dit ça vous avez une
forme une forme éblouissante on peut
dire votre âge non bah oui bien sûr
soixante ans par donc pas tout à fait la
queue aujourd'hui suis pas bon ménage
mais alors alors vous avez un secret
quand même c'est que vous dites lui en
âge non embrasse sub on n'est pas en âge
où effectivement vous avez un secret
c'est vous dit en fait nos sports comme
churchill sûr vous ne faites pas de
sport c'est le secret de votre forme je
me balade un peu quelques quelques
itinéraires à pied
ouais un peu de ski de temps à autre et
voila voila mais vous n'êtes pas ruiner
la santé oms est pas c'est bien la santé
à faire des jag et sûrement pas aux
normes heures bon mais c'est bien
parfois c'est un truc à savoir alors
vous êtes ministre de la culture je le
fus quand vous dites que vous l'êtes pas
personne ne vous croira que de façon
donc si vous
autant dire que voulez vous vous êtes
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères
c'est pas c'est bien comme job c'est
passionnant j'aime léger mais relations
internationales voyage en tout cas ouais
peu avant que je suis très casanier
alors jaurès à paris beaucoup en avant
vers les lorrains il ya eu valéry
giscard d'estaing avant vous lui et
c'est une autre stature ah bon lui il
avait voyagé déjà beaucoup les partisans
est ce que vous regrettez un peu votre
pré candidature de 95
c'est à dire en avant c'est de
l'histoire ancienne grâce à l'aca fait
qu'après vous qu'on soit au courant oui
ça vous regrettez pas de partie des
choses qui vous enrichissent il n'y a
pas de regrets mouais vous ne regrettez
pas d'avoir des jeux spa est un looser
ça a dépassé ma pensée et il a eu raison
de me donner tort
très bien répondu alors vous êtes maire
de blois là je termine curriculum vitae
vous êtes maire de blois ce qui vous a
valu le surnom de langue de bois mais
j'espère que ce soir j'espère que c'est
pas de moi c'est toi tu y redire ce soir
j'espère vous ne serez pas langue de
bois bon vous accuse souvent de courir
après la modernité alors aujourd'hui
excusez pas le sentiment d'être un petit
peu quand même sur le plan de la
modernité d'être concurrencé quand même
par cohn-bendit pour reculer on n'est
jamais assez nombreux
oui sauf que vous n'êtes pas des mêmes
partis aux deux parties nous important
dans la même famille d'accord est ce que
vous savez ce que ça veut dire courir
q uot 1er janvier pas spécialiste des
réponses comme ça bourque que vous lisez
non parce que j'ai vu que vous lisez les
inrockuptibles louis bozon c'est ce que
ça veut dire quoi non du tout bon non
c'est queer c'est alors je voyais
maintenant non mais c'est quand je fais
pas attention ces aiguilles r non blancs
non non c'est en fait la tendre queer
non la théorie queer c'est de dire qu'il
ya plus seulement les hommes les femmes
et les homosexuels mais qu'en fait il ya
autant de chèques ski adam vie voilà
c'est fait beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
alaoui bien sûr et c est cela de
répondre à cette question vraiment en
toute franchise parmi tous les
successeurs que vous avez eu à la
culture
je vais me rappeler très vite il ya eu
jacques eu tout bon il ya eu philippe
françois léotard par françois léotard
avant il ya eu tout bon
il ya eu 12 blazy maintenant catherine
trautmann qui a été le meilleur à votre
avis la meilleure s'améliore au fur et à
mesure est-ce que vous allez être
candidat du ps aux européennes voilà une
question qui ne s'est pas posé à mon
petit cerveau encore je sais que ça l'a
décidé vous savez que la décision
oui la décision va être prise le 10
février vous savez bien donc c'est dans
quinze jours les socialistes réfléchir
oui à cela prend du temps il faut bien
qu'on peut j'ai soupesé une greffe
partie pas une vie simone pas ne veut
pas de vous non je ne passais pas qu'il
veut pas il a dit que françois hollande
était un bon candidat
vous pensez que françois lamy sera un
bon candidat leur excellent candidat par
magna prenne de cumuler l'autre partie
du fromage y a pas de cumul c'est ça le
problème
donc vous savez pas franchement je ne
sais pas moi je trouve alors je peux me
permettre de vous dire ça vous feriez un
excellente quand je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas françois hollande au jeu ce pas
là 10 20
très bon candidat c'est bien un très bon
candidat il faut le choisir est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas victime finalement d'une
sorte de des mitterrand 10 à sion lionel
jospin cherche à faire oublier les
années mitterrand et mitterrand il nous
avait prévenus à que vous seriez pas au
gouvernement il avait dit on va
abandonner superphénix
non mais jack lang c'est vrai que vous
avez pas renier mitterrand est pourtant
il ya quand même beaucoup de choses qui
sont sortis depuis quelques années je
vais pas vous les listes et parce que
tout le monde les a en tête
bon vous malgré tout et c'est honorable
parce que veut dire vous êtes fidèles
malgré tout vous continuez à défendre la
mémoire du président mitterrand
plus que jamais et vous avez même créé à
blois un pont françois-mitterrand oui
bon est ce que finalement c'est pas ça à
votre problème est ce qu est ce que
finalement on pourrait pas parce que les
gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
gouvernement pourrait pas vous reprocher
cette fidélité alors que veulent faire
oublier ces années mitterrand je ne
pense pas que soient leurs problèmes
d'ailleurs si vous tendez mais jamie au
gouvernement en tout cas personnellement
je ne changerait pas d'un iota la la
fidélité une personne
j'ai respecté que je respecte et que
j'aimais je la maintiens plus forte que
jamais dire que c'est une question aussi
je dirais de d'éthique de vie pas
beaucoup ce mot mais je considère que la
fidélité à quelques idées ou à quelques
personnes avec qui on a partagé des
moments heureux ou malheureux fait la
noblesse de la vie si on si tout cela
est cassée qu'est ce qu'il reste de la
vie et du mas vous êtes fidèle à dumas
aussi à roland dumas voulais absolument
faire une galerie de portraits portrait
vous vous êtes le seul aujourd'hui qui
dit enfin des rares qui dit dumas doit
pas démissionner jeu trop loin expliqué
à 16h c'est quand même moi il est minuit
quoi quelle heure est-il 11h30 minuit
non mais comment soit christine
deviers-joncour après ça aurait été
sympa de savoir si vous étiez fidèles
vous à dumas parce que lui il ait pu
tellement fidèle elle enfin bon c'est
pas grave vous voulez vous en parle oui
c'est pas une question de fidélité dans
ce cas précis c'est une question de
principe par rapport à l'idée que je me
fais de la séparation des pouvoirs
il ya des juges d'un côté et elle est
juge de l'autre j'estime que tant qu une
personne connue ou inconnue n'a pas été
mises en cause de façon trouver
certaines il doit être considéré on l'a
proclamé il ya deux siècles que lui ne
s'en et ça vaut en particulier pour les
gens qu'on ne connaît pas qui tous les
jours encore malheureusement trop
souvent sont victimes d'arbitraire
multiples de l'administration ou de ou
d'abus policiers ou ou judiciaires a dit
vous êtes expliqué voyez ça pas pris ça
va a pris une heure et c'est clair mais
personne n'a dormi il n'y a pas de
mauvais endroit pour s'expliquer croyait
peut-être derrière ça aurait été mieux
bon alors on va on recommence on
continue sur vos idées politiques qui
nous concerne nous les jeunes quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya alors alors le
cannabis générac le cannabis de 30,6 au
tandem êtes partisans de la légalisation
de la dépénalisation supérieur qui
change la loi à genève comment je ne
sais pas au juste qu'il n'y a aucune
raison de désigner une le cannabis comme
le la messe le seul système de 20,2 de
drogue qu'ils soient pénalisés à ce
point pourquoi pas l'alcool pourquoi pas
la cigarette pourquoi pas d'autres
choses
voilà j'estime que l'insolite chaque
land vous pouvez sortir l'eau potable
est d'accord
cette bourde la légalisation du non mais
moi c'est moi je n'ai jamais fumé des
joints de ma vie que j'ai pas entendu
que la vérité c'est savoir c'est rare
non mais je suis honnête j'ai jamais
fumé des joints par contre je suis
d'accord parce qu'en fait ça change rien
c'est vrai que c'est pas plus grave qu
autre chose et que le fait d'interdire
ces idiots ça change rien qu'on moi je
suis pas pour que les gens fument des
joints mais je m'en fiche moi je
comprends vous entendez bien avec
laurent gerra moi même un peu réac
laurent non il est sain c'est d'arriver
un peu réac laurent c'est pas une
insulte à gérer axa veut rien dire en
face ça veut dire réagir à des shows et
vous a déjà emmené chez ses parents à
bourg-en-bresse
ouais mais alors c'est bien passé très
bien merci jack dont
j'accueille maintenant jack lang
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit
celui de la peinture oh lalala lalala
lors on regarde qui sait que 50 italien
non enfin dans l'âme et du coeur parce
qu'ils ont très très sale jack lang
mesdames messieurs donc très bien gérée
au laquelle cochon ce type oui c'est
terrible
laurent méfiez vous de ce type jack je
vois que vous êtes habillé en art 10 ans
ce soir pourquoi parce que vous êtes
hardison un accord très bonnes réponses
première bonne réponse de de jag la 0
mardi chauny verrait le jour où je vous
rencontre est alors on vous voit souvent
jack à la télé vous prêtant aux facéties
imaginé par les par les animateurs mais
ce soir je voudrais qu'on change un peu
de registre car vous figurer dans tous
les sondages comme un excellent candidat
possible de la gauche aux prochaines
élections présidentielles en 2007 donc
on arrête de rigoler on a en face de
nous mesdames messieurs peut-être le
prochain président de la république dans
ce sol comme une merde dans le carré
viiip qui va diriger un pays dans sa vie
riche et le pays aura routeurs les
enfants l'attention
al'inverse de lefa bus d'ailleurs qui
lui a la crédibilité mais n'a pas la
popularité voilà et il a par ailleurs
beaucoup de talent ouais c'est vrai
qu'il a toujours été très sympa avec
vous et lui et moi avec lui et vous avec
lui on va voir si ça continue jusqu'en
2007 voilà alors vous êtes socialiste
jack lang le plus populaire chez les les
jeunes et les ouvriers et vous dites
quand on vous parle de cette candidature
possible
pourquoi des sevrages les gens qui
disent compter sur moi donc il ya pas de
raison que vous soyez pas sur les rangs
en 2007
mais c'est une question qu'il se pose
pas aujourd'hui
un 2007 c'est loin comme un laissez nous
vivre
1 en gros c'est oui quoi nom en grosses
et nous sommes aujourd'hui et j'ai envie
d'agir
ici et maintenant toute une série de
sujets et ça va être chaud ps à être un
petit peu la guerre des chefs non et non
pour l'heure on joue au jour collectif
off
mais oui on joue collectif si l'on veut
gagner ce que vous dites là 2007 il faut
jouer correctement
et pas perso ouais bien alors vous avez
aujourd'hui jack lang 64 ans vous aurez
67 ans en 2007
c'est votre dernière chance si vous
présentez pas en 2007 façon après ça
sera trop tard
alors avant de passer au crible vos
idées politiques on va dire un petit mot
de l'école d'autant plus que vous publié
chez gallimard folio un livre de 768 pas
que j'ai lu je suis sûre laurent et
quelquefois c'est interressant ce oui je
suis pas d'accord avec tout mais ça yaya
au moins des volontés et puis on se
demande pourquoi tout n'a pas été fait
alors qu'il était ministre et c'est un
point de vue intéressant alors le titre
du livre c'est une école élitaire pour
tous ah c'est pas celui que j'avais pas
vu on n'est pas premier mois
sérieusement une école une école
élitaire pour tous
c'est un oxymoron en quoi c'est comme la
porte avril comme vous parlez bien tirer
c'est pas possible ça une école élitaire
pour tous précisément c'est serré c'est
le seul paradoxe de de ce qu'on doit
faire pour un col c'est à dire à fois
une école de l'excellence mais qui soit
en même temps une école pour chacun en
charge par quelle méthode vous comptez y
arriver et vous dites si à partir d'un
socle de connaissances solidement acquis
par chacun nous réussissons à libérer et
à reconnaître la diversité des
sensibilités des talents c'est la vérité
je crois c'est la donnée à l'ensemble
des enfants du pays une culture scolaire
de bas rhin et en même temps et
notamment au collège à leur permettre de
de vérifier ou plutôt de révéler leurs
talents divers à travers des matières
qu'ils choisissent eux mêmes
vous dites on ne peut accomplir un
changement qu en captant les ondes
positives vous rendez bien compte que
c'est très beau enfin je veux dire c'est
pas pratique c'est pas quelque chose de
factuel dans ce domaine de l'école sur
les autres on ne change pas en prenant
les gens de frau mais en essayant
d'additionner ce qu'ils ont en eux de
positif
ça m'a fait bien oui c'est pas faut
faire accoucher
1 ce qu'ils ont de positif et de
créatifs on ne sait pas plus rapide de
virer les mauvais abattement là c'est
rapide
c'est l'échec absolu voilà immédiat et
quelques-uns de mes collègues l'ont été
prouvée on ne les trouve aujourd'hui ne
cite aucun nom ne veux citer personne
il pensa ferry là à oui sûrement bien
alors là vous risquez pas de vous mettre
mal avec les enseignants parce que y'a
rien de négatif sur sur un vous dit en
parlant des enseignants
ce sont les serviteurs de la pensée dont
la noblesse et des veillées dans les
enfants le petit prince qui sommeille
page 72 pour apple non mais vous risquez
pas de vous fâcher avec eux la mais
pourquoi me fâcher avec le dire j'ai
beaucoup de beaucoup de respect pour eux
et je pense que le que le pays doit
avoir beaucoup de respect pour eux par
une fois un métier à la fois beau mais
très difficile enfin vous avez rien non
plus contre le corporatisme dont les
enseignants font montre certaines fois
vous dites être corporatistes et bien
souvent aimé passionnément son métier
riche et par exemple des formes sa
discipline par le prof de lettres défend
les lettres il aime passionnément son
métier quand le prof de maths défend les
maths 20 il aime passionnément son
métier et j'aime les gens qui aiment
leur métier
faut être un petit peu démago c'est vrai
des fois pour réussir en politique
il faut aussi avoir les idées très
claires alors comme vous parlait très
bien pour éviter que vous nous embarquer
dans des phrases comme ça on va faire
une interview
oui non
alors que j'avais coché oui non un ça va
être très dur pour vous jack lang très
dur serez vous candidat à la candidature
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2007
oui non joker ça commence à pensez vous
avoir les qualités jack lang pour
diriger un pays comme la france deuxième
joker
non non non bâti alors adressé très
grave je ne ris pas tu n'as que joker 1g
pas me porter une appréciation mais ce
que vous êtes en train de faire c'est
très grave parce que ça c'est ça fait
penser à d'autres hommes politiques
bien d'accord mais la question ne se
pose qui disent joker à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème on le gère deux
terrains serviront à rennes la dodge car
oui justement 2003 oui en 2007 la
question se posera différemment
pensez-vous jack lang que vous feriez
mieux que les autres
c'est possible donc c'est oui
pensez-vous être crédible au niveau
international un peu j'accepte sa toile
java où ça veut dire oui bah oui c'est
une litote oxymoron l'état oxymoron
l'état c'est l'espère la rhétorique ce
soir excellent grammaire n'est pas chez
cauet là c'est sûr alors jack
si vous étiez président est ce que vous
seriez pour l'arrêt augmentation de
l'impôt sur le revenu
je serais pour une égalité fiscale qui
passe inévitablement par l'impôt sur le
revenu donc vous remets trier l'impôt où
ils étaient avant tout pour refaire
toute la copie fabriquée par dacia
raffarin donc oui augmentation de la csg
pour boucher le trou de la sécu oui non
ce sera fait avant que l'eau chouaieb
les candidats à la présidence de la
république
est-ce que vous baissez le gouvernement
si s cube et seriez les crédits pour le
ministère de l'intérieur
oui non ce n'est pas une question
essentielle ap ap ap ap
pourquoi baisser les crédits il s'agit
de les murs et partir donc il ne sera
pas pour la défense doubiste aurait les
crédits il fait autre chose dans la
défense ne pas s'enfermer dans le
nucléaire et choisira système de défense
opérationnelle aujourd'hui qui permettra
à la france d'être présente sur les
terrains d'opération dakar ne sert pas à
grand chose
par contre la nasa doit pas dans
l'intelligence un an et demi
invention efficace et avait 11 phrase
non c'est pas ça c'est que de toute
façon pour la défense j'ai compris que
jack ne baissera pas les crédits mais
qui veut mieux répartir l'argent plus
affectés à autre chose acheter un truc
dépasser acheter d accueil par exemple
je serai avec hauteur c'est ce sont des
pensées de l'argent qu'on jette à la
poubelle
etes-vous pour ou contre la
régularisation des sans papiers
oui oui après une bonne réponse à
tapotage tapota la dépénalisation du
cannabis
oui non je suis pour une loi sur les
drogues pas seulement le cannabis
l'alcool le tranxène je l'aimerais je
suis pour que surtout au delà d'une loi
1 que l'on ait le courage d'organiser
une vraie campagne sur la santé publique
très bien informer les jeunes des
dangers qu'ils courent et pas seulement
avec le cannabis mais avec l'alcool et
d'autres drogues infiniment plus long
jour la télé réalité tout ça quoi
d'accord on peut en parler
est ce que vous êtes pour la
légalisation de l'euthanasie
oui parce que je ne comprend pas que la
france sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup
d'autres se cachent les choses et et
refuse de de légiférer et d'autres pays
je pense à la hollande nous imaginer des
systèmes dans lesquels il y a des
verrous des précautions dès des
commissions de médecins qui épaulent la
famille et qui décide
d'accord donc l'euthanasie c'est oui
l'indépendance de la corse
oui ou non non etes-vous pour ou contre
la dissolution du front national non
l'euthanasie pour le trouvais pas rendre
le front national victime
harry on voulait c'est le prix fort de
mon bac autrement par d'autres moyens
bien est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce
que la gay pride devienne un jour férié
elle est déjà quasiment jeté la
république jamais plus un enfant
n'aurait
pensée triste merci jack je rappelle le
titre de votre livre une école et
élitaire pour tous
[Applaudissements]
l'ong
vous connaissez tous les deux évidemment
que nous connaissons mais entendu depuis
longtemps depuis longtemps mais vous
entendez bien moi très bien non mais ça
tombe bien ça vous ennuie nom duquel ils
ont bien alors jack lang vous êtes
numéro 2 au classement des hommes
politiques préférées des français dans
paris match avec 69% d'opinions
favorables comme par hasard voilà c'est
par imad seront voilà alors vous êtes
derrière bernac wisner voilà alors non
mais c'est énorme quand même je ne sais
pas ça commence bien et ça commence fort
le mec il est homme politique numéro
deux préférés des français c'est quand
même pas rien tu vas dans un pays chaud
en pillant d'habitants bien alors dans
vsd dernière semaine de janvier jack
vous êtes le candidat ps préféré des
français devant le premier secrétaire
françois hollande
là je vous demanderai pas de commenter
parce que ça pourrait [ __ ] un peu de
bisbille au parti en a déjà assez comme
ça
enfin disons faut reconnaître quand même
que votre cote et elle n'est pas bonne
non mais c'est vrai c'est pourquoi
pourquoi d'imphy répond pourquoi
voilà je n'ai pas d'éléments
alors non c'est vrai que au sujet de
françois hollande vous avez dit je me
sens par rapport à lui à la fois
solidaire et libre donc on voit bien que
pour le moment bah voilà vous êtes dans
la partie dirigeante du ps mais que
effectivement le moment venu
effectivement peut-être vous saurez
prendre votre envol jack lang jusqu'au
plus haut sommet rien en revanche alors
il ya eu un dîner des amis de françois
mitterrand pour l'anniversaire de sa
mort début janvier et la fabius à serrer
toutes les mains
sauf la vôtre on sait par mégarde ah
ouais il n'est pas fâché je ne sais pas
il ya quand même du rififi européens' un
fabius a dit quand même en parlant de
hollande au dernier meeting la pente 1
il a dit holland c'est l'opposition
caoutchouc oui mais aussi une ces démos
du week-end ça qui passe qui s'oublie en
tous les cas votre position et patrick
ouch ou à vous puisque dès mardi dernier
vous aviez demandé la suppression de la
loi fillon
donc elle tous ses enfants toute la fin
de semaine dans l'est dans les rues et
ils demandent eux aussi l'abrogation de
la loi fillon qui va être discutée mardi
au parlement
est ce que vous croyez que le
gouvernement va l'abroger avant mardi
pour ça fait des mois et des mois que
personnellement j'ai tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant faites attention trop
suppressions de postes trop de coups de
coupes de crédit trop de restrictions
finira par finiront par avoir des
conséquences malheureuses pour notre
système d'éducation remettant à la fois
en cause l'égalité des chances et l
exigence j'irai d'excellence bon en ce
moment après trois ans disons de deux
coupes diverses sur place lycée par
lycée collège parker on s'aperçoit que
malheureusement et je ne m'en réjouis
pas franchement parce que je
personnellement je place l'école au
dessus de tous et de toutes
considérations lilliputienne de la
politique c'est très important et donc
je souhaiterais que le gouvernement par
rapport à cette confrontation sentir par
un acte fort par exemple un plan
d'urgence qui restituerait une partie
des postes et des crédits supprimés
mais quand on fillon dit en fait lycéens
ils sont manipulés vous répondez quoi et
parqués par mois on sait me prêter un
immense pouvoir que je n'ai pas pensé
pas ouais dites moi si c'est pas un
boulot facile quand même vous avez été
vous ministre de l'éducation nationale
quand luc ferry est là assis à votre
place il ya quelques semaines et qui dit
vous vous rendez compte ce thierry qu'à
l'époque jack lang manifester contre des
arrêtés des décrets qu'il avait lui même
fait voter
il a perdu la tête
je sais pas peut-être que dans un moment
de délire lorsqu'il vous a dit une
pareille chose peut arriver après tout
cas qu'ils ont c'est un filon c'est vrai
nom mais bon feriez quoi va aujourd'hui
si vous étiez misé ducation nationale là
dans les trois jours qui viennent je
crois qu'il faut prendre des mesures
positives concrètes vont renouer le
dialogue créé un climat de confiance
pour il se fait que dans mon histoire
ministériel je me suis trouvé dans une
situation très différente
on a fait appel à moi pour calmer le jeu
en 92 une première fois et en 2000 une
deuxième fois
bon ça devient un métier mais comment
comment calmer le jeu bon en établissant
un rapport de respect et non pas de
mépris de confiance et non pas de
l'indifférence
et puis il faut quand même dégagé un
minimum de ressources et de moyens
vous n'avez pas l'air d'accord voix non
est ce que vous préparez vous déjà qu
est ce que vous connaissez un ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui n'ait pas
eu de souci qui n'est pas été décriée et
par les appareils par les autres y en a
pas sinon celui qui a été nommé à 20 ans
elle serait toujours là dans le plus
grand satisfecit général suffit que les
étudiants descendent dans la rue il
suffit que enfin ils ont tous sauté plus
ou moins les uns après les autres parce
que ça n'allait pas d'extérieur
j'ai eu la baraka peut-être j'ai eu la
chance et surtout non j'ai succédé pour
pourra atténuer mais quelques mérites à
deux ministres excellent mais qui eux
avaient connu des difficultés
c'est plus facile d'arriver un pour
calmer le jeu ouais vous êtes comme le
meilleur à la télé jaxx d'accès d'accord
c'est le meilleur jean-pierre que
simplement c'est un des meilleurs
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai et
alors
maintenant quels conseils quels conseils
donneriez lourd un jeune homme politique
débutants pour la télé par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire qu'est ce
qu'il faut pas dire rock en toute
matière d eau paraît faire banal et je
ne donne qu'un conseil travailler
travailler travailler
non sérieusement et oui sérieusement et
comme je comme les moyens sont en vérité
j'ai pas tellement intelligent je bosse
beaucoup
en plus j'aime ça c'est ma drogue 1
après vous vendez bien votre travail
quand même si on est convaincu si si on
en croit si émouvant ça veut dire quoi
te dire si on croit quelque chose si on
a un idéal si on aime vraiment une
conviction
on a envie c'est même le devoir de la
faire partager de la transmettre
c'est le minimum vient pas chez ardisson
pour dire qu'il adore les carottes
râpées industriels voilà ce qui a été
signé bien pour des erreurs de fabius
grosse erreur je cite et personnel moi
je citerai il a fait une grave erreur là
laurent et c'est vrai alors jack lang
tout le monde parle de vous tout le
monde parle de nelson mandela
depuis son intervention à londres à la
veille du sommet du g7 où il a mis sur
le même pied
la pauvreté l' esclavage et l'apartheid
avec cette phrase historique make
poverty history
c'est à dire faire de la pauvreté un
souvenir du passé alors tout le monde
parle de demander là ça tombe bien parce
que vous publiez un livre sur lui qui
s'appelle nelson mandela leçon de vie
pour l'avenir chez perrin avec une
préface du prix nobel de littérature
nadine qu'ordinaire qui dit le plus
grand bien de vous d'ailleurs au passage
donc vous raconter en fait dans ce
bouquin
la vie de mandela et quand on le lit on
se rend compte d'une chose terrible
c'est qu'en fait la part tail été mis en
place après la deuxième guerre mondiale
en disant d'abord interdiction des
mariages interraciaux puis des relations
sexuelles entre personnes de race
différente classification raciale de
tous les sud-africains interdiction à un
noir d'occuper une position hiérarchique
supérieur à celle d'un blanc et on se
rend compte que tout ça a été fait
finalement après la deuxième guerre
mondiale après la chute du nazisme
le parti qui a gagné en 1948 le parti
blanquer gagnants 48 est un parti qui
était favorable au nazisme et oullins 10
mai contre le contre les alliés alors
face à ça à mandela comprend que la
situation n'est pas comparable à celle
de à celle de l'inde à celles de gandhi
et qu'il n'y a pas de solution pacifique
finalement on l'avait pas il est très
très influencé par gandhi puisque vous
savez gandhi a longtemps milité en en
afrique du sud et longtemps
mandela et ses amis de la la mc honte
penser que seule la non-violence
permettrait de de faire bouger les
choses
puis lorsqu'ils se sont aperçus que rien
ne bouge et il est il voulait il voulait
par des actes qui épargne la vie humaine
s'attaquer à des points névralgiques
dillon de des infrastructures sud
africaine s'est tué des gens quand même
ça pouvait éventuellement tuer des gens
et tout était fait par mandela qu'un
très grand respect pour la vie humaine
pour éviter qu'il n'y ait de des dégâts
humains si j'ose dire il y en avait et
il très peu cela peut durer l'air très
longtemps pour mandela puisqu'il s'est
fait mettre en taule très vite
voilà son procès s'est ouvert et il a
failli d'ailleurs être condamné à mort
et il s'est retrouvé 27 ans 27 ans au
bagne puis en prison et pourquoi il n'a
pas été condamné à mort c'est tout était
écrit pour qu'il le soit marie je crois
qu'une des raisons parmi les raisons il
y avait sa détermination
connaissance du droit sa passion du
droit sa connaissance de son dossier
sa capacité à a plaidé lui même avec
autorité devant les juges
et puis une équipe de juristes tout à
fait exceptionnelle mais qui lui avait
clairement dit nelson tu as 90 chance
pour cent d'un d'être pendu celui qui a
fait la plaidoirie est la plus
importante et à la fin il est 17 choses
très fortes
si cela est nécessaire
je suis prêt à mourir pour mon peuple
ses avocats ont tout fait pour qu'ils ne
disent pas cela et je le dirai il a même
dit je ne ferai pas appel de la
condamnation
donc si vous me condamner à mort je ne
ferai pas appel
et disons que si on voulait aller
jusqu'au bout il y avait dans le système
sud africain une sorte de passion aussi
du droit comme dans les pays
anglo-saxons et mandela et ses amis
savaient merveilleusement joué des
procédures comme un martyr aussi
peut-être
et ils ont eu peur aussi de faire un
martyr c'est un argument qui a joué
sûrement l'apartheid se termine en 1990
à ce moment-là mandela chef de guerre
devient chef de paix et quand il était
au pouvoir il se venge pas il fait pas
de nuremberg et jugent pas tout le monde
il fait la commission vérité et
réconciliation où les gens à partir du
moment où ils disent oui pendant
l'apartheid je me suis mal conduit ils
ne sont pas condamnés
c'est extraordinaire ça fait c'est
effectivement c'est une des raisons pour
lequel le personnage je crois qu'on doit
être connue notamment des jeunes
générations
la chose extraordinaire chez mandela et
ses amis d'avoir pu réconcilier
l'ensemble des sud africains de créer ce
qu'il a appelé une nation arc en ciel
blanc métis indiens noir blanc et de
tendre la main aux blancs qui avaient
été les tortionnaires en leur disant si
devant une commission
vous dites vos crimes vous les
reconnaissez vous en excuser vous serez
pardonner
en tous les cas il a peut-être réussi un
truc que nous on n'est pas arrivé à
faire par exemple en afrique du nord
quoi dire qu en afrique du nord les des
français sont partis et il aurait pu
rester et créer une société différente
et lui la réussite en afrique du sud dès
l'origine en effet exemplaire je crois
d'une réconciliation nationale et qu'il
avait imaginé dès sa jeunesse
je suis contre la supreme suprématie
blanche disait-il
je suis content aussi la suprématie noah
et je veux créer une une nation je
répète arc en ciel où chacun puisse
vivre avec chacun finalement la seule
tache noire sur la légende mandela c'est
sa femme winnie mandela quoi qu'on a
qu'on a quand même accusé peut-être
d'avoir commis des crimes
winnie s'est battu notamment à soweto et
elle a soutenu le peuple la jeunesse
elle a gardé l'espoir
bon un moment elle a peut-être on ne
sait pas au juste commis un petit
dérapage et mandela là aussi je dirais
grand seigneur lui a pardonné
[Musique]
j'accueille jack lang
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacob bonsoir très très élégant très en
forme vraiment pour une telle émission
il faut être élégant au moins dans
l'apparence alors il ya un mois vous
annoncions chez claire chazal votre
candidature à la candidature
vous disiez l'expérience m'a enseigné la
sagesse sans me faire perdre ce que j'ai
en moi deux fois d'énergie et de ferveur
c'est bon c'est pas mal
levier préparer ça je le sais je le
pense très profondément
non je crois que il ya un moment dans la
vie où on a la foi je dirais la maîtrise
on croit tout cas avoir la maîtrise des
choses et puis on se fait virer comme
des merdes
cependant les ce que je dis je deviens
un petit peu souple d'autres alors il y
aura donc un vote des militants en
novembre mais certains d'entre eux se
plaignent qu'on leur en pose d'ores et
déjà ségolène royal par les médias et
les sondages
partagez cet avis jack non je crois que
ce qui a lieu aujourd'hui nous sommes en
mai sera très différent en novembre
prochain
et quelles que soient les pressions ou
l'est où les invitations ou les les
exigences des uns et des autres je crois
que les militants choisiront librement 1
et ils se poseront des questions simples
quel est celui des candidats le mieux à
même par son expérience cette vie déjà
aller virer à ségolène
non là l'expérience dont j'ai rêvé
qu'elle est celui des câlins de
l'expérience
celui ou celle des chronos d'argent
c'est une chance très bien merci de
corriger alors je le répète
quel est celui ou celle qui par son
expérience sa connaissance de l'appareil
d'état et puis je dirais son imagination
et à la vision pardon pour le maître
servi jackson là ça va être un enfer
c'est la marque
une attitude je tuais ltte essayait
quelques l'obs d'édiction alors non ce
n'est pas terminé
par conséquent mais bon voilà fini c'est
bien pourtant mais alors le numéro deux
du parti socialiste françois rebsamen
lui distingue en il est vrai nom c'est
une peur que ce soit une savane ce jour
saison lui distingue au parti socialiste
les présidentiables autoproclamé et les
leaders évident je crois que c'est une
distinction qu'il a fait un jour ou un
soir je suis pas sûr qu'il ait réédité
depuis
oui mais vous vous considérez comme un
présidentiable autoproclamés ou un
leader évident finalement et si j'étais
les deux a autoproclamé parce qu évident
très bien bravo ça c'est la première
déclaration du numéro deux du ps
françois rebsamen
il a fait une deuxième déclaration il
invite les candidats à se retirer devant
ségolène dit vu qu'elle en tête dans les
sondages ce serait un kaki et d'autres
candidats à la candidature mais aussi
une espèce de désignation formalité en a
sorti en conséquence et c'est l'ifop la
sofres eux c'est ça
mais après tout pourquoi faire voter les
militants bah oui pourquoi faire voter
les français sont attendus français on
pourrait transformer le vote en une
sorte d'immense machinerie électronique
voilà dans laquelle l'ifop la sofres et
le sessad et si des noms mais avec ce
raisonnement qu'on peut comprendre qu
elle que je respecte par ailleurs
françois mitterrand n'aurait jamais été
élu
ils étaient battus dans les sondages
trois mois avant le scrutin par giscard
d'estaing balladur aurait été président
de la république il triomphait deux mois
avant le scrutin sur chirac est quand à
lui et j'ose pas malheureusement on a
trop cru les sondages
on a cru qu'il serait élu haut la main
et beaucoup se sont crus par conséquent
autorisé aller gambader s'abstenir ici
voter pour l'un et pour l'autre et le 21
avril est arrivé voilà il faut se méfier
des sondages c'est ce que disait le
les intrus man il disait simone il avait
écouté des sondages les hébreux serait
toujours en egypte formule belle formule
il faut croire d'abord à la conviction à
la volonté à l'entêtement alors tu vas
même un petit peu du mépris pour les
militants quand même non vous avez écrit
hollande prudent et du respect de
l'éthique non absolument il m'a répondu
par une lettre amical tu as raison
et il ya le volet 1 résume les gens qui
c'est moi qu'ils ne foulent pas je
résume donc ça va tout va bien et tout
baigne ouais alpes où leur pour l'heure
mais ceci étant alors au long du thé
très très fâché samedi dernier à
marseille parce qu'il y avait une espèce
de colloques comme ça sur le sol
l'éducation par yahvé pafa bulls
n'avaient pas dsk y avait pas vous il
fait même pas sa femme
oui c'est parce qu'il ya eu de grands
malentendus sur l'un louis sur la
participation à ces états généraux
les uns dix ans les présidentiables
n'ont pas à être là d'autres disant il
faut qu'il soit là c'est secondaire ce
sont de petites péripéties de la vie
mais quand même déjà si vous n'arrivez
pas à vous mettre d'accord la
maintenance et c'est secondaire
hollande a dit on est là tous les
samedis je sais pas où sont les autres
je suis la boîte tous les jours sauf le
samedi
[Rires]
non mais vous travaillez vachement vous
en faites pas ce que vous ouvrez des
chantiers de réflexion vous publier les
conclusions alors vous avez déjà fait
l'école des institutions l'immigration
vous allez faire la fiscalité les
relations internationales et en
attendant nous publié chez grasset un
livre qui s'appelle vaincre le chômage
donc c'est vrai vous vous carburez un
grave à la voilà un travail sur un
projet oui c'est vrai alors la
principale mesure de jack lang pour le
chômage pour vaincre le chômage c'est
près de faire une grande fête du chômage
ou les gens descendraient qu ils sont
descendus dans la rue étaient chômeurs
pour danser
[Rires]
non non plus
plus sérieusement vous dit le chômage
est une spécificité française en vrai
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours
l'impression que l'europe entière est
couverte de chômeurs en fait en france
est beaucoup plus grave qu'ailleurs
c'est vrai que la france est un pays
sur ce plan la déception mais
d'exception triste alors que le taux de
chômage dans les pays scandinaves en
espagne en grande-bretagne a reculé
la france est toujours un taux élevé
au-dessus de 10% mais voilà pourtant
quand même on est de dison la lutte
contre le chômage est à 65 milliards
d'euros c'est pareil 1,65 à donner
chaque année pour lutter contre le
chômage
est ce qu'avec ses 65 milliard d'euros
pourrait pas payer les gens tout
simplement parce que vu qu'on les
dépenses sans qu'ils trouvent de travail
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas leur donner ça
ferait ça ferait du pognon pour les
chômeurs certains trouvent du travail
mais disons que c'est en effet beaucoup
de gaspillage avec beaucoup d'efficacité
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans ce
livre je propose une réorganisation
complète de la politique de l'emploi va
vous dites il existe une voie
social-démocrate de retour au plein
emploi mais d'abord il faut relancer la
croissance est toujours inquiet mois
comme j'entends ça parce que les gens
disent il y aura plus de chômage quand
je serai là mais d'abord on va relancer
la croissance est initialisée de le
décréter ce serait formidable
nous avons montré sous le gouvernement
jospin la croissance sous l'influencé
d'une politique volontaire a été une
époque de forte croissance et à ce
moment là quand même
rappelons des choses simples ont été
créées près de deux millions d'emplois
mais c'étaient des emplois peut
subventionner les angles subventionnés
sur ces deux millions c'était 300 milles
avant donc j'ai vraiment essayé de m'en
passer quelques trophées il ya eu à
tandja ce phénomène qui est considéré
par les économistes comme exceptionnelle
sur du football qu'est pas coup de bol
donc toute volonté avant alors voilà
vous avez eu huit chantiers contre le
chômage laurent créer les emplois du
futur déjà un goy par exemple batum
technologies dans les domaines nouveaux
2 1 de l'aéronautique aux
nanotechnologies en passant par les
biotechnologies et donc le japon la
suède les états unis consacrent 4% de
leur pnb à la recherche scientifique et
en francs la somme -2% away est la clé
la croissance bien sûr et la réinvestir
dites vous dans la série réside dans
l'intelligence avait sur la maîtrise sur
l'obligation scolaire jusqu'à 18 ans
jack au moins sera pas moins de chômeurs
qu'il faut quand même les garder jusqu'à
35 en bourrique ya beaucoup de
redoublants son marché du travail je
obligations secret à ce qu'elle disait
je crois aux obligations scolaires de
trois ans il faut que dès le plus jeune
âge on s'attaque où on plutôt
préviennent l'échec scolaire il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une politique de
la petite enfance encadrant mieux les
enfants permettant en effet de ddd paul
et d'accompagner les enfants venant de
familles en difficulté bien l'autre bout
de la chaîne il faut absolument mettre
si j'ose dire le paquet sur
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche lors allemand tel budget de
l'éducation nationale
c'est normal et on va descendre quel
budget pour augmenter sud éducation il
ya quelques larmes et achi sur lesquels
on peut revenir les exonérations
fiscales en faveur de super privilégiés
qu'il faut remettre en cause
il ya certainement à tailler dans
certaines des places 1k
que dirait pas non il va morfler la
nomma il a dit que super bon ensuite
poursuivre allocations pour les chômeurs
qui trouvent un emploi une de vos
mesures cirque c'est pas parce qu'ils
ont trouvé un emploi il faut pas
continuer ad et des noms c'est à dire
qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est un phénomène
connu des personnes qui bénéficient de
ce qu'on appelle des minima sociaux
s'ils trouvent un emploi trop précaire
il le refuse pourquoi parce qu'au bout
de deux mois ou trois mois ils perdent
tout est donc à l'image de ce qui se
pratique par exemple au canada ou dans
les pays scandinaves
je propose une allocation compensatrice
de revenus pendant un certain temps un
l'avantagé que ces personnes sont
remises au travail retrouve une minimum
2 c
irrité par conséquent c'est pour les
comptes sociaux c'est pour la situation
de l'emploi un plus
et pour ces personnes un peu de bonheur
et un peu de en tout cas un peu de
bonheur de vivre et faire financer le
chômage par l'entreprise qui licencient
mais ça c'est une idée que je l'évoquent
je ne reprends pas à mon compte
directement c'est une idée d'un
économiste français qui vit en amérique
olivier blanchard un remarquable qui
considèrent en effet que l'on devrait
faire payer les individus sans ciment
par les entreprises qui licencient
je m'interroge je suis pas sûr que on
peut le faire pour les très grosses
entreprises ou les petites ce serait la
ruine absolue alors ce qui trait
incroyable tout ce que vous dites là en
fait c'est que tous les exemples que
vous prenez c'est toujours au danemark
en finlande au canada en irlande en
angleterre dire qu'en france c'est la
personne qui avait 10 des sommes énormes
et si c'est horrible put un temps où la
france diriger le monde et aujourd'hui
on est des baltringues maintenant il ya
une armée non pourquoi jack sérieusement
pauvres
si c'est pas inquiétant quand même que
la france ce grand pays allait chercher
ses sites et faire son marché
la france ne manque pas d'aidé il n'y a
pas de raison de ne pas s'inspirer de
solutions positives pratique à
l'extérieur d'ailleurs je les fais dans
un autre domaine
lorsque j'étais en charge de la culture
ouais n'ai pas inventé tout seul comme
un grand dans mon coin
j'ai piqué des idées en italie arrêt des
idées en bretagne des idées aux états
unis et à vous maintenant tu crois que
les idées sont là pour qu'on pour les
pieds pillon nommer les meilleurs
rassurez-moi à la fête de la musique
c'est bien vous quand même c'est moi
jason le chômage j'ai dû mener chez
grasset
[Musique]
en tous les cas vous avez l'air très en
forme jack ça va la santé excellent
excellent c'est vrai je fais quelques
envieux
un parmi mes petits camarades fait ce
qu'on prend comme faire un petit
interlude chez kate jack
qu'est ce qui vous rend malade quand
vous venez à la télé le trac
or mais ça va mieux là puis quelques
instants
beauvais ouais qu'est ce qui vous donne
mal à la tête aujourd'hui dans les
discours de jacques chirac
un sorte de vide
ouais mais l'homme vaut parfois mieux
que ses discours
qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir dans le
gouvernement de villepin actuellement
l'art du mensonge
qu'est ce qui vous fait mal au coeur
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez sarkozy
sa voix de karcher photocopies
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous fait vous arracher
les cheveux au ps aujourd'hui est-ce que
je manque de cheveux non pas vous
qu'est-ce qui vous filent un nul c'est
la conventionnelle de 20 heures sur tf1
le l'enfilade de kata quel homme
politique vous donne le plus de boutons
pas un homme politique c'est ce régime
politique dans lequel nous vivons qui me
donne beaucoup de boutons et c'est
pourquoi il faut le changer qu'est-ce
qui vous démange en ce moment l' envie
de me battre et de gagner la dernière
fois que votre coeur s'est arrêté de
battre c'était pour qu'ils vont monique
amis qu'est ce qui vous a mis la
fillette pour la dernière fois
gilberto gil 20 14 juillet place de la
bastille qu'est-ce que vous prenez comme
excitant dans la vie le boulot le
travail je me shoote au travail un peu
de cocaïne quand même pas besoin le
travail le travail le travail
je suis un drogué du boulot à quelle
idée êtes-vous allergique à tout ce qui
porte atteinte à la dignité humaine
quel chanteur de charme au fil du
diabète à ses mauvaises heures dominique
de villepin qu'est ce que vous entendez
moins bien en vieillissant pardon
chômage
publié chez grasset mais la mission
[Musique]